you know we stream this on youtube
there's gonna be a whole lot of people
watching it we need to make them upset
that they're not here with us
so i'm gonna count you guys in you guys
go nuts i'm gonna scream
all right
movies in the tin roof san diego kevin
and mark are here for fat man beyond
[Applause]
[Music]
did we lose an ad okay
internet issues let's see
experiencing technical difficulties
please stand by
wow let's see how this goes oh [__]
are we there i think
did we do it i think we're live
uh oh let's pretend that we let's
pretend that do the [__] cheer again
[Applause]
oh my god we're such [__] that's all
we do it for the love and [__] like that
uh welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
[Applause]
uh we are here at the movies pop-up at
tin uh roof inn at san diego man put
your hands together so the folks know
you're real
[Applause]
uh continuing with our comic con
coverage this is day three of the san
diego comic con we're all down to comic
con having a blast everyone enjoying
comic con so far
[Applause]
uh today's big day comic-con of course
they're doing the marvel panels soon
they did the dc panel earlier today the
warner brothers panel and stuff uh i do
a panel uh later on at hall h and show
the first five minutes of uh clerk's
three so it's uh it's a
yes [__] yes uh there's i paid people to
say that
uh very very exciting day man this is uh
the big the culmination of everything
tomorrow don't really have much i'm
doing a breakfast here with members of
that kevin smith club but other than
that
headed home and stuff so khan is coming
to a close in a big way
big bad way
last night yeah
you went up
to the eisner awards where you were
nominated
for your amazing book
i did adora and the distance
and when we last left the show we were
all pulling for you and stuff
tell us what happened last night tell us
a story about the eisners and berry
bury the lead bury the lead yeah tell a
story about that i should leave what i
brought under the table don't bury the
lead very okay
uh
so the eisners in case you don't guys
don't know it's sort of the oscars of
the comic world and every year they they
have a host of judges who decide what's
to be nominated and then the comics
professional feel that large gets to
vote
it's held at the indigo ballroom it's a
it's a like four hour long affair
um the it's the best parts of the oscars
you never see
anyway it's uh it's there's booze which
is helpful um it's filled with every
comic book professional you can imagine
that happens to be in town so it's like
rock star faces and names rocks are
facing the name there was one award a
series of awards was given out by neil
gaiman and frank miller together
wow yeah like that's deep that's big um
so i'm kind of sitting there at the
comixology table with my my co-creator
ariela christentina my editor will
dennis jock is right across the way
drinking his face off because that's
what jock does i'm not sure if you guys
know jack
he's a scot who lives in london who
likes to drink and can because he's
genetically predisposed to it and uh and
so we'll just kind of hang out and they
start going through the categories and
we're like they're like hey did you
write a speech like i didn't write a
speech why would i write a speech like
well you're totally going to win like
no don't say that
um
because i have as we said last night i i
prepare for disappointment so i can only
be surprised by that and as i said last
night there's no way that you don't
[__] win this award
i did not win this award what
oh my god
i hate to say this but recount and stop
the steal man like
how the [__] did that happen uh i i have
no idea i have no idea but i
was not invested in victory yeah it's
true he hasn't been this whole time i've
been more invested in his victory than
he's been invested in the victory i had
high hopes it would legitimize this
[__] show
yeah
victory it is a victory yes
here's the question i have though yes
yes
had you rightfully won
yes you've got the floor what would you
have said uh i i think hold on let's do
it right ladies and gentlemen the winner
of the [__] eiser for best
[__] ever
mark [__] bernardin
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
here's your award oh thank you
i i
i just want to thank the academy yes and
all the members of the golden globes
uh no i mean the speech ultimately would
have been that i've been in comics for
about 20 years first as a journalist
and then as a professional but before
that i was a fan
and so to be in this room with a bunch
of other people who love comics as much
as i do and have helped create the
comics that i've loved since i was a kid
it's a very special thing so thank you
to comixology and to my co-creators and
to
you know i suppose whatever higher power
you guys believe in i'm an atheist so
what says clutch exercises me and buddy
christ here um
you know and to everybody who liked the
book and bought the book and told other
people to buy the book and at the end of
the day my consolation prize was i was
at a signing today and this 13 year old
kid came up to me his father was kind of
pushing him forward he's like hi my name
is alan i really love your book i'm also
on the spectrum and it's so good for me
to see somebody like me in a comic book
thank you very much
and i'm like if i get
any of that
then that's that's more to me than a
buddy christ yes [__] doll yes
i think they lost the threat of the
metaphor i think so but but their spirit
is absolutely right
um what else did you uh so at that point
do you get like super drunk or what well
at that point like i sort of hung out
for a bit in my malaise and my nice
slight meagering depression
and then just like watched other people
have their dreams come true right you
know and like hey you go have your thing
you go get recognized you all did great
work everybody here did great work some
people get little tin trophies to take
home other people just get memories and
being able to say hello to legends and
friends and so that's pretty much what i
did that night i did that for a bit and
then i i very gently ducked out and went
to a party and hung out with friends
some of which are here some new friends
and some old friends and
[__] it because comic-con
is less about
you know getting awards and it's less
about getting recognized for anything at
all and it's more about the people you
meet and the conversations you get to
have and the random collisions with
wonder that you encounter over the
course of a day so that's what i did
[__] beautiful give it up for a man
uh the best reward though is always cash
so send people at home
where can they buy a dora in the
distance where can they support the art
they can buy it any place comic books
are sold it's a dark horse uh print
edition so go buy that one
dark horse
and uh tomorrow between one and two is
the last time that i'm signing at the
comixology booth on the floor 23 14. we
have lots of books to sell ariella will
be sitting next to me making me look
better and doing sketches inside if it's
a thing that you want
excellent man so come say hi
um well i've the story didn't end the
way that i wanted it to end but like
that happens from time to time it does
and still
yeah involved
true but you get what you need uh well
you're a big winner in my heart in the
hearts of all these people give it up
for the true winner
mark bernard ladies and gentlemen
uh okay as previously stated i've got a
hall h panel so i'm actually gonna haul
ass about midway through the show
um to get ready for that but there's i
love you as well but i haven't left yet
so steve the eulogy i'm
still here
uh the good news though is that uh we
got a guest to bring on and that guest
is uh going to uh not only take my place
but be far better than me uh that
what is it
it is not liam neeson
i mean now whoever i bring out people
are going to be like wow i didn't know
liam neeson was an option
i heard did you hear the [__] uh they
did a panel i heard this from the lions
gave folks they did a panel for uh
directors
uh and it was like
tim miller that kid tim miller that boy
boy tim miller boy director tim miller
who uh directed deadpool amongst other
things um and two other cats
who worked on like one of them who
directed the last three john wick chad
stahlelski yes and then so i forget who
the third cat was
andrew stanton thank you so they do a
panel with these three directors
and they said that the panel was like
attended well but not you know people
are like yeah but where's the marvel
[__] and whatnot
guess what happened at that panel they
[__] showed a trailer for the new
john wick movie yeah and then
[__] john wick came out [__]
keanu came out man
so let it that'll teach you man [__]
if you see a patty like just directors
[__] keanu's in the wings man
that's the kind of magic that happens at
comic-con the other magic that happens
at comic-con i heard was in hall h this
morning yeah uh dwayne the rock johnson
show dressed up in his best cosplay
and got [__] elevated into the sky
with a [__] in the darkness so it looked
like he was flying and then he [__]
did this [__] with his hands and
everyone had lanyards around them that
then lit up with the [__] lightning
bolt logo
we're just showing the first five
minutes of clerks i
[Laughter]
there's no aerial show i'm not i mean
this is i am wearing the costume kind of
but like [__] they went all out for a
movie that everyone's going to go see
anyway
now hey listen there used to be three
weeds
back in
back in the days there used to be this
technology uh vincent price had a movie
called the tingler that came out of the
theaters in the 50s and they used to put
little [__] electrodes in seats so
that when [__] happened that was scary
on the screen it would jolt you in your
chairs yes next year just make it kind
of tickle your balls while you're
sitting there just the tickler the
tickler
my necklace lights up we tickled your
balls
this is how i hold on to [__]
relevancy in cinema man by bringing
[__] technology like the tickler in
yeah
kids
shut the [__] up
holy [__] man like [__] we're here
for you but like maybe once every 10
minutes not every statement and [__]
good
good i don't want to interrupt your show
but we're doing a show
anyway uh speaking of guests man uh and
hopefully [__] when we have a guest
don't be like
like
we don't want to scare him away he's a
good [__] guest
um he's been with us uh before but he is
of
this world ladies and gentlemen uh he is
[__] deep in pop culture he writes
comic books he's been in comic book
[__] movies and tv shows uh he's one
of my favorite people in the world he's
a hell of a [__] actor he's been on
things that i've done as well and right
now he's gonna hang out with us and chit
chat for a while talk about his comic
talk about his experience here at comic
con maybe get some movie dish out of him
please welcome
dave despaultian ladies everybody dave
get over here dave just mulching
[Applause]
oh my god look at this [__] jason muse
was just saying before he was like i was
just re-watching all of flash and i was
just on the abracadabra episode and dave
came in
and it was like [__] abracadabra came
to life and i was like you stand next to
silent bob at all times
[Applause]
and then we bring it back down sorry to
disappoint liam neeson was not available
yes
but liam needs some is here so
you saved me for making a joke i was
about to regret megan
what has your comic con been like dave
um
my comic-con's been amazing before i
forget it though the tingler is one of
my favorite movies i knew you would
[__] tackle so
maybe my nickname in high school but no
seriously i the cinna family in
hollywood used to do on halloween they
put the buzzers still under the seats
vincent price legendary anyway my comic
con has been amazing um i've had so much
fun you guys i've gotten to promote the
things that i love and care about i've
gotten to see so many people it's been
so [__] long since we've gotten
together like this and get everybody
together and just like celebrate all
this [__] that we love absolutely so um
yeah [__] hoot and holler about that
man
you guys we all just collectively
endured like one of the most insane
[__] things we'll ever experience in
our lives and we made it we're here
[Applause]
and comic books are not dead and movies
are stronger than ever
kevin smith is not dead
still [__] here
i feel like you want me to buy something
yes
mark bernardin hi
didn't win in eisner did not [__] it
what you're [__]
so good your book is so good if you guys
haven't got it go buy that [__]
immediately it's so good you're a lovely
man dave
thank you uh let's talk about your book
thanks count crowley let's talk about my
book dark horse title dark horse i heard
a good shout out for dark horse earlier
yes
um this is a passion project for you how
long you've been working on it i've been
working on this i mean in my mind since
i was
probably 12 but i've been writing the
comic now going into year five um and
we're just about to finish
this new arc of volume two of the comic
uh the pandemic and [__] just
stopped things in their tracks for a
minute when we were starting to build
momentum and there was a minute when i
thought the comic was done dead in the
water and then thankfully dark horse
came back around and were like
let's give it another try and this new
volume has been thank you it's been
doing very well um
so yeah it's a dream for me i grew up in
kansas kansas city kansas um yeah
and uh i grew up loving speaking of the
tingler i grew up i grew up in a really
religious house and i used to have to
sneak
downstairs
late at night not to do what kevin's
gonna probably insinuate but no to
watch the late night creature feature
because like horror movies were banned
in my house comic books were banned in
my house d and d was banned in my house
and i used to sneak down and watch the
the late night creature feature called
cremation ortom's friday nightmare
cremation was my fir next to tigra
cremation was like my first
spank bank you know thing that's cool uh
you said you weren't going to talk about
what kevin and i did
yeah yeah yeah you said i would be the
dirty one all right
did you say talk about
yeah yeah well i so i would go
downstairs and watch cremation boredom
and and i always loved that
that world of the late night horror host
and i had that idea even before i saw
fright night with roddy mcdowell about
like what if a horror host actually had
to
um fight a real monster horror host who
thinks they know everything about
monsters and what if all that we think
we know about monsters is actually wrong
what if it's all been a lie what if
we've been fed all of this fake
mythology and information so that they
could actually turn us against one
another and that's the reality of the
comic book that i started which is
count crowley the first volume was count
crowley reluctant midnight monster
hunter the new volume that's out right
now you can pick up a latest issue at
your nearest comic shop or on the floor
of uh san diego comic-con is cal crowley
amateur midnight monster hunter
nice there's an arc there we're going
places we're going places what's next
hmm did i see you're doing professional
crossover or something you guys
yes
it's happened i read this correctly you
read correctly what is it i'm doing it i
did it i wrote it i've seen it it's
[__] beautiful i got to do a one shot
with steve niles give it up for steve
niles legendary
amazing creator
steve uh for decades has been telling
the tale of cal mcdonald in his criminal
macabre series which he has been writing
for forever it's an amazing story about
a dysfunctional alcoholic problematic
monster hunter cal crowley is about a
dysfunctional alcoholic problematic
monster hunter uh so steve and i got a
chance to introduce those two characters
to one another who happened to meet in
our story here's a little bit of spoiler
for you guys at a con that's how we
found the way to make them
nice
and then the [__] hits the fan and
things go off the rails coming out
october 23rd from dark horse comics look
at that man what is it like writing for
somebody else's character
were you a big fan big fan and it's it's
intimidating at first but um he's super
super rad and and the way we did it um
was we passed pages back and forth i'd
write a page he'd write a page i write a
page he wrote a page so
me finding cal's voice when i would when
i would ever get something that he said
didn't feel authentically cal he would
just change the voice a little bit if
anything ever didn't feel totally right
as a jerry line i would make a little
adjustment but honestly it was pretty
simpatico and we wrote the whole thing i
mean we passed back and forth within two
days we were we had 20 pages it was so
fun i would wait for his email and then
i'd write and then i'd send back and
then he'd be right back at it it was
really fun and we were talking about
this last night me and mark back stage
of the show what an amazing medium it is
comic books because you could be so
collaborative with somebody and make
something so meaningful and not even
meet them in real life dude i mean just
via email or is it like mark the person
who drew your book right my artist she
lives in jakarta indonesia and i've met
her twice now well three times at this
show
and we've been collaborating for four
years at this point
lucas kettner who draws count crowley he
all and lauren half who's my colorist
and frank kovetovic who's my
my letter
i've never met frank i've met lauren
once and lucas and i have met very
briefly twice in five years it's crazy
nuts and yet these are passion projects
no one would argue that like what you
wrote came straight out of your heart
what you just told us came straight out
of your heart your childhood and stuff
like that and yet here we are trusting
ideas very important ideas to utter
strangers and it all works out yeah a
collaborative effort man this is the
power too of like the editor and the
importance of when you look like what
does a comic book editor do they do more
than just make sure you didn't [__] up
any of continuity or that there are any
spelling errors they're really great
editors like a really great producer
where they know how to bring the right
talent together the right personalities
the right kind of people in their
communication styles and i've been so
lucky you guys i've been making
movies now for a little while i got my
first break in 2007 when i got to film a
small part in the dark night ever oh the
dark knight
and
that guy that guy's like i knew i knew
him from something i knew
he was sitting there the whole time
going what do i know him
it was that or the wendy's commercials
but yeah
[Laughter]
and and and i've been but i've been
consuming comic books since i was nine i
mean i've been like devouring this [__]
i've been eating the donuts my whole
life i've always been dreaming of how i
would make my favorite flavored donut
what sprinkles i would put on what what
kind of cake i would use what kind of
icing it would be would it be hot would
it be room temperature i knew exactly
but i never knew how to [__] make a
donut it was the weirdest thing when i
finally pitched my idea and a publisher
said yes
i was like
i don't know how to actually make a
donut so then i had to go learn and
luckily friends like kevin and mark i do
pick their brains a lot about a lot of
[__] and you guys are always really
supportive and helpful
donuts yeah
yeah
he's cheering on the metaphor yeah i
love it you killed it it was that good
of a metaphor let's talk about you
mentioned the movies man let's talk
about them let's talk about the movies
uh so you were in dune last year right
[Music]
are you i was are you going back for
part two which just started filming uh
we're filming today here at san diego
comic con you heard it here first dune 2
has kicked off production um there's a
sand lot out back behind no i um
who saw dune that came out last year yes
[Music]
incredible film achievement in cinema i
mean it's to be a part of that guy's
vision in any way shape or form is an
honor as you know denis has now put me
in three movies in all three movies he's
killed me mercilessly so what would they
have to say the first one was prisoners
that was the first time i worked with
denny was prisoners which we shot in
2013. and then blade runner blade runner
and then uh now dune
and i was hoping for more piper i was
like is this the piper story did you see
my last shot in dune i'm like this dude
yeah i was relatively sure he's not
coming back unless it's in a picture on
a mountain there's flashback
opportunities for faker degrees you
heard it here first mark bernardin
straight out of the news of san diego
comic-con he opens a convenience store
that's right
um but yeah man that movie was what is
it like working i may i work on little
movies what is it like working on those
gigantic movies that go for months and
months and months
oh man it's
i i i can only say
uh
for me the experience has been a dream
because the ones that i have been on
have been dream projects you know dune
the suicide squad unit these are these
the huge projects i've been on that i
didn't like dark night i was there for
two weeks so i can say that was amazing
that was incredible but like i was not
a big part of that film in the way that
like some of these other films i got to
be around the process and to be with
phil this is [__] rolls down the hill
right you always know that wherever you
work if the main boss is like an [__]
it just trickles down
and
it it for me the first time i was on a
project from beginning to end that was a
big studio project was
ant-man
and on yeah
man
peyton reed payne reid is lovely
these are
amazing people who love the material
they love comic books they love movies
and they're good human beings who have
good hearts who actually believe in what
they're doing those that experience on
ant-man was like a dream ant-man and a
wasp a dream on the suicide squad james
gunn the guy has a heart james gun
ladies and gentlemen
he has a heart as big as hall h and the
guy you feel it on set it's an amazing
experience denis
truly
hands down beats everybody in like the
kindness department even you kevin i'm
sorry to say because you've got to give
it to him he's canadian of course he's
nicer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
french canadian taboo add that taboo to
boot
but that
the world's amazing on those and then
and also i've just been really lucky the
kinds of actors i've gotten to be around
like big movie stars and cool and people
who i've never had to deal with like
the the horror stories that you hear
some actors tell you know i've been like
so lucky i mean like
i don't know if you all might have
noticed i did have a a little appearance
in the reboot did anybody see the reboot
i mean
i was on that same and see the the guy
running the show
was really nice and it was a really fun
experience yeah i actually i i come back
from dune and shot that with you i don't
know if you remember that you were done
with dune and you came to i i did a test
in budapest with the the bald and
everything
flew back to you i had pneumonia
and we shot in that new orleans heat in
tax gear yes and then i flew back to l.a
and i think went to the hospital my
wife's here somewhere but yeah i was
like on death's door yeah what was it
like to go from something like dune to
something small like reboot man like
number one tiny trailer no food i'll
tell you exactly what it's like it was
like the here's the thing when you're
with the filmmaker yeah who has been
dreaming about telling the story or love
lives with these characters their whole
[__] lives who loves the work
as much as anything else who just gives
it their all it was a [__]
joy dude the joy in your i was there day
one i was actually in shot one of the
reboot watching this guy's
little kid eyes light up and having
the [__] quick stop and having
everybody there
so for denis denis villeneuve who made
dune that guy since he was 12 has been
dreaming of these characters has been
thinking about dune and has been
figuring out the way so honestly the
sets look different the the costumes are
different it's a different kind of story
but the the vibe that energy that
there's no difference to me i i love
that's what i love about and and and
life is so short especially after
everything we've been through the last
couple years you're just like
[__]
it's gonna go so fast who am i going to
spend my time with who are the creative
collaborators who are the people is it
the people that are that that that are
going to
make me feel
like they are doing exactly what they're
meant to be doing and are living in that
in that place of bliss where they're
creating the and telling the stories
that they dream of those are the people
that i want to spend my time with those
people i want to give my energy to and
i'm doing it
holy [__] man
that's the realest [__] and this guy
this guy they live and breed this [__]
and they live it like they're they will
they live it and that's that's what i
aspire to do did you hear that he's one
of us ladies and gentlemen easily one of
us
very much so so
you're clearly very
of handling the show i'm going to leave
the show in the very capable hands of
mark
and dave here man they're going to take
you all the way home stay as long as you
like boys we're going to talk about some
[__] that happened at the con today i'm
going to see how dave feels about what
we saw i'm just going to ask him some
stuff about movies that he's in that he
shouldn't tell us anyway you're filling
very small shoes my friend but based on
what i just sat here listening to my god
you're going to inspire the [__] out of
this crowd and what i'm going to come
i'm going to open up twitter later on
and it's going to be a sea of people
being like kevin shouldn't host fat man
beyond anymore
that's what i'm saying they're going to
start calling a tall guy with weird last
name beyond
bad joke already i see how i lead thank
you tell him how to say your last name
it's very easy you gave me a mimetic or
whatever mnemonic that that is go ahead
do it this small chin you got a small
chin say this small chin this mulching
just mulching this small chin and that
[__] small chin because it's so it's
like got 96 letters but the way he
explained it to he's like just small
chin i've never forgotten i always see
you in my head is eve still here
i always give you
credit kevin did she did you invent that
yeah that's yours so you said the small
chin
and that's why you get married but but i
always say you taught me that you taught
it to me
so she taught it to you you passed it
off and i'd give you the credit for
steve oh
nice [__] the credit belongs to you
give it up for dave's wife man
all right kids i'm leaving you in charge
dave's wife day's wife dave's wife
wait a second
bye kev bye kevin have fun in hall age
all right here we go
we got rid of him the wheels come off
the bus
right a [__] way
right away so what what have you gotten
to walk the floor at all
i did i hit the floor um briefly
yesterday today i got to go to funko
village uh i don't even stop by funko
village it's insane what they've done
it's so crazy because this funk goes
everywhere but then you go to actual
funko town
okay you know where i'm going with this
yes
and i did go and i will take you too but
we went to funkoville
they've got the polka dot man pogo man
like sold out the funko polka dot man
sold out and they had some there so it
was cool to see but what they surprised
me with was they had a there was a funko
custom of
my wife
uh because she's a painter and they had
done there was a funko of her splattered
in paint with her tattoos and everything
and i was like
boom life achievement yeah well done no
matter how much i screw up the rest of
this weekend you guys she's still
going to take me to bed
fabulous what's the coolest thing you
saw on the floor
coolest thing i saw on the floor was in
um at sideshow collectibles they've got
this
really fantastic new bella lugosi
dracula sculpture that is
and there's a harley quinn did you see
the new heart did you go by there oh my
god there's a harley quinn sculpture
that is like
it's insane man it's a piece of art it
is it's a masterpiece but the bella
lugosi dracula one is cool there's like
smoke coming off a candle there's all
kinds of crazy [__] it's amazing uh so
who's gonna be at the at the dinner
you're going to tonight
i don't know i don't know i'm gonna get
to go hang out with some of my marvel
friends you know i've spent a big chunk
of my career working with marvel i got
to be an ant-man ant-man and the wasp i
got to do marvel's what if
um so
fortunately although i
didn't get to go and participate in the
hall h celebrations i'm going to be
seeing them uh this evening and then
i'll be
texting you all of the dirt that i'm
able to please do yes and if there's if
there's seat that's left for elijah as
should be yeah there should be um if if
there's like hey we we could use like a
little black elijah
yeah i'll let you boy yeah yeah i can be
jewish for the night if you get me to be
okay just so i can my my plus one my
plus one elijah oh
dave you're so sweet
uh and where once you leave here where
are you going are you going to a set are
you going back to work are you making a
movie i am going
i just wrapped a movie and right now
we're figuring out i'm figuring out what
is the next thing that i'm going to be
doing but i just wrapped this really
cool movie i've been in australia the
last two months just made a movie called
late night with the devil
it's set in 1977. my character is like
this the guy who's so far behind johnny
carson in the ratings with the late
night talk show competitions
uh
that his name is jack delroy that he's
about to get cancelled and jack's wife
had died a year previous and instead of
dealing with any of it he just kind of
has pushed through
and now he's about to get canceled so on
halloween night
1977 jack delroy
ends up doing the most shocking things
he can possibly do on live television to
try to um
boost the ratings and he ends up having
basically a complete nervous
breakdown and just
you'll see [__] goes crazy does he have
sex with a live pig
that's the one thing he was gonna do
yeah and then they decided that that was
probably not gonna
i mean i'd watch a show where a dude
[__] a pig on camera yeah yeah i won't
say i enjoy it but i tune in because
there is on my channel there is i will
say there's no [__] pigs but there is
a giant
oh man i don't know what i'm allowed to
talk about there's there's things you're
gonna see that are so gross that are so
disgusting that i had to like walk off
set sometimes and like have a pallet
cleanser yeah outstanding um
so do you want to talk about some [__]
that happened at the convention yeah
yeah what happened tell me what happened
what's the news okay what's the
scuttlebutt what's the scuttlebug this
is stuff that i was not able to see
because i was at my signing and you've
been off doing cool [__]
uh and kevin has been similarly off
doing cool [__] so
harvested from the internet and
occasionally personal like somebody who
went to a thing told me a thing are you
a star trek fan dave the small chin
i i love star trek i don't know if i
define myself as a star trek fan so i
don't know how much i know i do love me
some star trek it depends on which
iteration we're talking about too i'm
really happy with what terry mcaulis has
been doing with this new iteration of
star trek i think it's very cool they
they they had a big star trek universe
panel today yes they showed off a
trailer for star trek picard season
three yes which is the next generation
season so everybody's [__] back but
they also announced that they were doing
a lower dex strange new worlds crossover
oh
see
where jack quaid's character ensign
boymler and tony newsome's character
ensign mariner are appearing on strange
new worlds
and there's an episode that will be both
live action and with some animated
segments wow that is really cool that's
nuts how do you feel about that i feel
[__] awesome about it like one of my
favorite things that i ever saw
was
um
uh h john benjamin voices both sterling
archer and bob belcher yes
and then i think it was like the season
five premiere of archer
that like he had lost his memory and had
been working as a short order cook and
they crossed over with bob's burgers
like the crossing of those streams is
always super [__] fun yeah yeah and
if you could cross star trek streams
then i think that's great that's amazing
that's amazing yeah h john benjamin and
chris parnell there's a couple of these
guys who voice
so much of the animation that i watch
and it's ridiculous because it's not
like they're doing crazy character
voices they're just their
voices that are so good on the ear i
guess they just found this empire of
voice over work it's kind of amazing
like this is my speed do you like this
speed great orchard or rick and morty i
mean parnell does tons of great voices
it's insane it's amazing speaking of
animation yes um zack snyder
is going to appear as himself
on teen titans go
[Music]
[Applause]
but uh the heroes are gonna find
themselves in the warner brothers lot to
find a director who can shoot their
landmark 365th episode that's amazing
and so the person they they rope into it
is zack snyder who will be playing
himself and it does happen to be the
365th episode of teen titans go who
watches the harley quinn show on hbo max
[Applause]
[Music]
and who knows who's going to be
appearing in this season of harley queen
show who's that
james gunn
did you know that james gunn is going to
be on harley quinn did you know that i
did know that what do you think about
this uh speaking of zack snyder what do
you think about the big uh article this
week are we getting into that um
we can we have a bunch of schneiderverse
fans here in the house okay
uh
i i do you want to kick the wasp nest
i know hey what do you say we want blood
yeah
who's getting nervous kevin up on the
screen just did this that's why i think
kevin knew this was coming i got to go
home at you guys
i gotta bounce this is too hot for me to
handle
uh listen i i uh i am a fan of fans
i am all about people who love the
things that they love
uh even if i don't respond in the same
way to the things that they love i was
not the biggest fan of the snyder verse
um i think that there are moments in
each of those movies that are great i
think there's moments in each of those
movies that feel misguided i think
fundamentally he has a take on
superheroes and superheroing that i
don't necessarily respond to right
i 100 allow for people to dig with that
and vibe with that that's your thing
great
the thing that i don't have room for in
my life
is the fringes of any fan base who find
ways to
denigrate or exonerate or in some way
make feel lesser than those who disagree
with the weaknesses
that's a great way to put it excellent
yes amen amen amen so we're all allowed
to to love we're all allowed to have
descent this is the thing for me i so i
started with dc the first job i did talk
about getting caught in the crossfires
of like toxic fandom i did a
dc movie that is the movie that changed
the way we look at superhero films it
was called the dark knight yes i am
gonna name drop that movie this whole
talk because
it's a special movie to all of us that
movie changed a lot of our lives and me
in a very special way that launched my
career as a as an actor then when i got
a chance to be a part of the marvel
universe with the ant-man movies i was
so excited to be like sharing with
people
i'm gonna be in the mcu now i'm like i'm
gonna be a character in ant-man
and i got
like attacked from certain people and
these are fringe people remember i don't
think this is the general consensus of
fans
i don't think it is the way people are
but people were like like as if i'd
betrayed the dc universe because i went
to do something with marvel and um so i
have been asked like what do you think
what's better is it marvel is it dc is
it marvelous dizzy what's better what's
the better thing and i'll always know
that i'm the guy that actually knows the
correct answer to that are you ready
whatever it is here it is
they're just different no yes they are
they're both amazing they're both
different for me personally
i would always air towards my favorite
is
the marvel superheroes and the dc
villains ah that's my favorite that's my
favorite i love dc villains and i love
marvel superheroes but
they're both amazing they're both
amazing and so i think that the the
thing about you know the article that
came out of rolling stone talking about
part of the campaign to get the the
snyder cut to happen involved you know
internet bots and kind of in fueling and
enraging and stoking
the flames of derision and division in
order to help amplify the voice print of
what that was
and hate is easy
like you know i was a critic for a long
time and it was always it was always
easier to write a bad review than a good
one because the hate goes faster it
spills easier sure better flows yes but
to justify why you love a thing takes
more because you have to you have to
like cognify it and you have to solidify
it you have to be able to communicate it
and so the idea that you would then fuel
the hate because the hate was louder
right is distasteful to me and we have
to figure out a way to define what a
digital space is now because for all of
us the safe space was going to a brick
and mortar comic shop it was going to a
convention and now it's even a more
inclusive space than it was when i was a
kid when i was a kid it was pretty
inclusive it was for all of us like who
maybe didn't have
fit in everywhere that we went but we
knew that we fit in with the film geeks
and the horror geeks and the the the
people who read star log and the people
who had fangoria like we had this safe
space to come so digitally we just have
to create a safe space where
i mean i can take it i get i i'm in
stuff people don't like what i do that's
fine i just ignore my wife's really good
at like keeping me clear of this stuff
but i the the toxic people it's so sad
how like how loud they amplify the voice
can amplify when someone says something
really mean to me or when someone
attacks me because i'm gonna do a marvel
movie when i started in dc and by the
way to those people that did that
[__] you because then i went back and
just did a dc movie last year called the
suicide squad which i'm incredibly proud
of
and maybe i'll go back and do a marvel
movie again someday who knows who knows
or a dark horse movie or an image movie
or a uh whatever mark bernard and dave
dysmunch and we'll start our own comic
book label and we'll make our own movie
and kevin smith if he's lucky we'll get
invited to come and uh
maybe direct some for us yeah
you know thank you
so like ultimately the reasons why we're
here the reason we go to these movies
the reasons why any of this happens is
because people love a thing and so let
them love it and if you don't happen to
share that love that's fine but when the
love turns to hate which turns the
threat which turns to evil which turns
to anger which turns to the dark side is
when it's bad so it's amen like live in
love and let well uh there was a
metaphor in there uh aphorism i [__]
up yeah you know look at my die is that
it
no i don't think living legitimize the
right matter yeah yeah yeah um let love
rule let love rule there we go show us
on the doll where the bad man touched
you
no that's not it that's not it
does this
rag smell
funny so anyway zack schneider's going
to be on teen titans go you guys there
it is you heard it here first we brought
it back around we're second or third or
third
um
warner brothers like kev said had their
big presentation today and yes the rock
did descend or sm yeah
that's amazing um the thing that did not
happen that was rumored to happen was
that henry cavill was allegedly going to
show up oh
he did not show up
uh
so i sorry not like i crashed this car
or something
were there any other like big giant
revelations so far like what has anybody
been like their mind was just blown by a
thing
um
so far not that i dave just mulching
being on uh
did you hear what what cover of the
hollywood reporter this week
i mean i think the sandman presentation
today went very well because everybody's
[__] stoked for sandman yes i think
the interview with the vampire stuff did
sort of surprise people because oh cool
i hadn't seen a trailer for that yet so
they dropped a big one it's like oh it's
sumptuous and gorgeous and it's in new
orleans cool that's great um that makes
me really happy because i think that
mythology is really rad and i think it's
a really fertile place to tell like
television storytelling but if it's not
sumptuous and new orleansy and louisiana
and it doesn't have that feel that vibe
that anne rice got so
just perfect it's very sexy yeah that's
great that's great sweaty like you feel
ready sweaty with the sweat because
everybody's wearing a [__] suit yeah
it's like
new orleans in august is just crotch
weather and it looks like everybody's
got that sheen from like swampy yes
swamp ass yes swampy ass vampires that's
so fantastic
nothing hotter oh the name of my new
punk band swampy has vampires swampy ass
vampires uh and uh and
yeah no [__] and funny there it is
that's the
count crowley defeater of swampy ass
vampires thank you i'm stealing that
i came up with that idea no one else did
yep just you
um we we cannot know what's happening uh
right now in the marvel panel in hall h
i know
so what is this kid
it's like oh i know what's happening
everyone was anastasia
what's the internet saying have they
told us yet
i'm telling you anything uh it was
rumored i'm hoping for some black
panther stuff i'm hoping for some
quantum mania stuff i'm hoping for some
the marvel stuff i'm hoping for some
did did they do they drop anything about
young groot today uh i am good was
yesterday it's a series yeah yeah they
they announce it yeah okay they
announced that hey they showed a tiny
episode of one of the little shorts
great the second season got what if is
what if it got its second season i think
uh spider-man freshman year got our
sophomore year fantastic um but i know
that there are uh members of the black
panther cast here these people have been
spotted they have been spotted lupita
nyong'o were spotted in san diego so
that bodes well it does bode well some
wakanda [__] can i ask who was seen do
you know
who who have we seen
lupita is the only one who's been like
legit on the ground here in san diego
okay cool um but uh and there was a
rumor that went around the internet that
marvel has started to trademark some
names
for upcoming movies
some of the names which again it's a
rumor i don't know how [__] real this
is but they sound dreamy uh avengers
secret wars
dead yes i am dead if they
can if i okay guys we're starting the
campaign here
david dis motion
i'm gonna grow my hair a little longer i
mean i'm weird enough i'm not just big
enough but i could put me in an
all-white jumpsuit i am the beyonder
right [__] yes
kevin mr feige you heard it i'm sorry
they've all said that we got a unanimous
we did it cheer
i feel like is that true that's a rumor
this is the room that's floating around
that these are the titles of these gods
avengers secret secret wars
[Music]
[__]
yeah kang such an awesome villain too
such an amazing character can't wait
um captain america new world order
really how where are you hearing these
rumors the internet these these come
from a site called culturecrave
who said that these have reportedly been
trademarked by marvel captain america
new world order holy you know which we
know they're making a captain america
for
yeah yeah and so it does sort of make
sense and sam wilson is captain america
yes yes yes i buy all of that and
finally the multiverse saga
i mean here's the wonderful thing about
the multiverse saga if that's true
you
what's cool about
something like that is you can take all
of the
earnest authentic
rooted in the comic book
character development mythology favorite
story lines that you love from all your
favorite writers if let's say you are
the helmer of that or your architecting
or
engineering i should say
that
reality and then
your imagination can just go wild that
would that makes me really excited that
give me a lot of hope what did you uh
and and were there any there hadn't been
any announcements about moon night uh no
announcements season two night i mean i
don't know about one division still
because it did feed so directly in yes
um
and i don't know about ms marvel except
we know that she's going right into
um
into the marvels marvels and there was
also
marvel zombies they did drop some
information from that and kamala khan is
going to be one of the main characters
in the marvel zombie show
marvel zombies we have marvel zombie
vans in the hands i love when horror and
comic book worlds collide did you watch
what if did people here get into what if
if you haven't watched it yet you got to
check it out it was really awesome did
you see the zombies episode i did yeah
i'm all about this one that was awesome
and i got munched
[Laughter]
that's actually the death of kurt
oh i mean he got eaten by zombies but it
was a glorious death
if you gotta go it's a good way to go if
you gotta go it is a pretty good way to
go i've died in everything you guys i
mean squished by starro
um
poisoned by
you know leto atreides like i mean but
there is an ant-man 3 coming out soon i
know but kurt is
yes yes you're right well hey
they wrapped principal photography i
think for ant-man quantum mania when
november but it's never too late it's
different
you heard it here first like we need to
smouch get him on a plane uh no i'm just
i i i'm so grateful i got to be a part
of the stuff that i did get to be a part
of with ant-man and um i don't know i'm
assuming a lot of people in this room
are comic book people i am the nerd that
always fesses up to the embarrassing
reality that my first monthly series
that i collected was the west coast
avengers we've talked about this there's
no embarrassment my introduction to hank
pym and it and then that was the rabbit
hole for me that led me into i mean moon
night was a part of that's how i
discovered moon knight for god's sake
it's how i discovered
wonder man and my i told you guys
earlier one of my first crushes tigra
but um
all the ant-man mythology
i i
i rabbit hold because of the west coast
avengers and i love
i love it i love the character i love i
love scott lang and i love what they've
done with those movies i cannot cannot
wait to see what peyton is doing with
quantum mania outstanding uh we are all
out of news um which traditionally we
would go to q a
we don't have any prizes to give away
but we can still answer some [__]
questions if anybody wants to talk
specifically like you can ask me [__]
all the time you don't get dave
desmolchen very often so if you want to
know some [__] from him who's been in
some of the biggest movies of all time
now is your chance we got time for three
questions he wants to know some [__] the
first answer is yes come on up
oh yeah you can ask me whatever you want
only on tuesday only in the dark stand
on that side testing yeah
swivel over to that side sorry sorry
buddy so we can catch you in the camera
there
hey hey uh i was wondering
sorry i was wondering could you please
give us your craziest story from the set
of the dark knight all the interactors
you got to interact oh my craziest story
from the dark knight um
yes here's the craziest story i have
from the dark knight
i was um
i had filmed the parade sequence and
getting shot and being in the back of
the ambulance in chicago i was a chicago
theater actor when i got that job i was
uh i was
i was i was a living struggling actor in
chicago and i got the chance to be in my
first movie we shot all that stuff so i
got to really know who the character was
by that point and i and i felt like i
really kind of got what he was looking
for
and it was an amazing experience then i
had a like almost
a month off
and then the entire production moved to
london
and i went to london to shoot one scene
which is me tied to the chair when
harvey dent is interrogating me with a
gun to my head flipping a coin and
batman saves me well
that was one day of work but they put me
on what's called weather cover which
means
it might rain and when it rains we're
going to shoot your scene because
everything else we're doing is exteriors
so they flew me to london i lived in a
hotel
the room of the hotel room i was in the
bathroom of that room was bigger than
the apartment i was living in in chicago
at that time
i got to spend
22 days just waiting every day for the
phone call and they'd say oh you get
another day you get another day enjoy
and they would pay me to sit around and
do nothing i'd never experience it
finally the time comes for me to go make
my scene happen we shot at the battersea
power station which is the building on
the cover of the pink floyd album
animals if anyone's a pink floyd fan
i
go up into this old abandoned crazy
battersea power station
tied to this chair
i'm so
terrified and nervous because this is
actually the first time i'm gonna say
lines and i'm gonna speak and it's like
i've been waiting now a month getting in
my head about how i don't want to ruin
this and i've developed this character
who can only giggle he can't actually
speak words and when he does it's just
what he's trying to say doesn't connect
that was the the struggle i was trying
to create as a character and um
so we get to it it's the first time i've
ever seen batman in person can you guys
imagine you've been collecting comic
books since you're a kid and there's
batman standing next to you i'm like oh
my oh god oh god oh god any and here's
harvey dent standing in front of you
flipping his coin so the first full take
that we do
of the scene
we go
like hit it hard where he's flipping the
coin he's yelling at me he's got a gun
in my head and i'm like i don't know and
then all of a sudden
batman says would you but i forget what
his line is but he says something to
stop him from you know hurting me and
he catches the coin there it is yeah
what does he know he's a paranoid
schizophrenic catches the coin mid-air
um
so we do the scene and i'm doing my
character
i'm i'm in it i am in it
and all of a sudden and these are very
serious act christian bale and aaron
eckhart one of the reasons they bring
such incredible work to a comic book
movie is because they don't treat it
like a comic book movie like christopher
nolan does it he doesn't go oh i'm
making a comic book they make none of
these amazing people do james gone you
know you don't
you don't achieve what they do by going
it's common they're very serious and
their performances were really serious
they were really giving it their all
and i never imagined in a million years
they started laughing
and they like broke like the scene ends
and they broke out in laughter i know
you know this story but they were like
laughing really hard
i was mortified you guys because this is
the first time i fully gone into full
crazy character and i'm that bad
that they're laughing at me the whole
set everyone is like dying laughing
and i was like
well
thankfully christian bale who's standing
is closer to me than you are he's like
kevier
he looks down at me in full batman
regalia
and sees me like this
and and he's like hey and i was like i'm
sorry i'm sorry he's like no no no no
they're not
we're laughing because his coin landed
on my bat head
so i guess when aaron had flipped the
coin and chris and christian came in to
catch it mid-flight it landed on the
cowl on the top of the cowl and just sat
there
while i'm trying to have this in serious
scene
and that broke the ice and then we had a
great shoot after that
[Music]
outstanding i just wanted to say i went
to the dark knight nine times in
theaters i know that's not enough but
your facial expressions in that movie
were haunting awesome work thank you so
much man thank you
thank you thank you uh anybody else got
a question for either of us question oh
sorry i pointed at somebody are you okay
and him okay get three total right
i mean we're not giving [__] away it
doesn't matter so you come first
we can do this you have to leave yeah hi
i saw you earlier come a little closer
keep coming stop there you go okay so
you just mentioned you've died in like
everything you everything so if both of
you had a chance to be in an awesome
death scene in a comic book movie who
would you want to be murked by
oh
i'd want to be murk by god emperor doom
wow that's some [__] uh who would i want
to be killed by in a comic book movie i
feel like i would like my death it
requires me no no we don't even need
that it's magneto
who pulls all of the iron out of my
blood
the hard way yeah
and so i like suddenly i just begin to
like red come through your urethra
oh
you you you one-upped it
you yes ended my horrible death uh but i
don't hate it
i don't that's beautiful death yeah no
thank you i was going for crimson and
this guy like and directed by david
cronenberg it's it's uh the cronenberg
gil del toro del toro yeah yeah you know
amazing amazing sweet i i would love to
play a villain that's so despised that
you just hate so much who has killed so
many good people
that by the time spawn finally gets his
hands on him like to see when spawn goes
to work the way that spine can go to
work and really cause
suffering and pain and death i i think
that would be a really fun kind of gory
death that i would i would be happy to
do on camera that's good yeah i will
we'll work on that all right let's make
that happen mr mcfarland thank you
thanks man all right so you sir had one
could you could you just talk about
um
like if you were talking to yourself in
high school because you came up in like
high school shawnee south yeah like
uh doing theater at your high school if
you could give advice to yourself who
like this goes out to a global audience
if you were talking to yourself what
advice do you wish you could give
yourself back then i think about that a
lot because now i'm a dad and i've got
kids and i
dad dads
i would have
sat down and had a really long uh
i would have had a long conversation
where i tried to spend as much time
listening as possible
to that that 16 year old version of
myself and and listened to everything he
had to say everything he felt like he
needed to say and then i would have
imbued this very s
soundingly simple but is not simple as
we know as adults advice which was um
i wish that i that i would have been
able now i don't wish i would change
anything because if i could change
anything it would have i wouldn't be
sitting here right now with all of you
people okay so i don't want to change
anything
but
i'm sad when i think about how much
suffering i had to endure because i
didn't understand the importance of
mental health i was somebody who
was
was absolutely in need of
mental health and and that can be
therapy for some people that can mean
sobriety for me it meant both uh and i
wish that i would have had a
conversation because i didn't have an
outlet i definitely had the creative
chops i think at a young age i think i
had this drive to be an actor i think i
had a lot of good instincts as an actor
as a storyteller but what i didn't have
were the resources to
to protect myself and to heal myself
take care of myself and i and i turned
instead to like you know drugs and
alcohol so i wish but it's it's not
always drugs and alcohol some people
it's just
just being in a dark place for longer
than than than they should be we all
deserve
you know serenity happiness is a fool's
errand because we all know even a really
well-lived life you're only happy a
portion of that time right you're an
idiot if you're like i'm not happy all
the time
then i'm failing at life that's just
crazy but
you shouldn't be self-loathing as much
as i was hating myself you definitely
need to help and be able to ask others
for help that was a lesson it took me
way too many years to be able to learn
and i and i and i sometimes am haunted
by the fact that i lost many good years
of creative output because i was
destroying and hurting and hating myself
so much as an artist
again i don't take anything back we're
all meant to be sitting where we are
right now and that's all for a great
reason but if you're out there if you're
struggling if you're suffering if you
feel like you're alone you're just not i
know it feels that way but you're not
and you can go for free resources at
samhsasamhsa.gov
it's cheesy but it's a great hub for all
kinds of free resources for you to go
and get help so that's what i would have
said thank you
i didn't mean to take it
no that's totally fine i have uh no
advice for my younger self other than
that girl ain't right for you boy
she's gonna [__] you up
but similarly one must go down the path
that is set before them otherwise they
don't get to the places where they need
to be amen amen yeah so man don't trust
that girl and one last dark night story
i
when i was uh
when i was when i was in the throes of
my addiction i lived in a car and i used
to sleep in that car uh and and i'll
tell you miracles happen in life and you
got to believe in yourself you got to
take care of yourself first no one's
going to do it for you but you can
definitely get the support and help you
need from from from your friends your
family or just from the anonymous
strangers of people in meetings or
through therapy but
when we were marching down lasalle
avenue as these cops in disguise who are
really going to try and assassinate the
mayor because we were with the joker we
marched by the alley where i used to
sleep in my car that was a god moment
that was whatever you want to call it
that was a real moment that i will never
forget for as long as i live and if
you're feeling hopeless if you're
watching this you're listening to this
right now if you're feeling hopeless i
couldn't have been more hopeless than i
was when i was living and sleeping in
that car and to think that it was only
seven years after that that i was
marching down the street dressed like an
officer
in a christopher nolan batman movie
think about it that's crazy
well listen i cannot think of a better
way to end a podcast than on that ladies
and gentlemen have you had a good time
love you guys thank you
if you've had a good time it is entirely
because of the gentleman sitting to my
right
thank you dave dusmalton for filling in
for kevin smith thank you famous on the
hall 8 stage
and that is fat man beyond for this
afternoon my name is mark bernardin
dave dis mulchin
tune in
whenever we do this again
which i don't know because kev's going
on tour but wherever it will be we'll be
on the same fat time same fat channel
smodcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
good night thank you tin roof thank you
movies thank you all for coming out it's
been a great time
[Applause]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the
aka ask have anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith